Like should you, should you not go into it because do you see a lead generator?
Is that what you're asking?
Yeah, exactly.
Because is there, is there at one point, uh, too many or too much competition?
So here's my theory is like, if, if everything checks out, right.
And I do the due diligence from what we talked about in module one and even with the lead
generators site or their, their organic site and their GMB, I do that sheet and it's still
open.
There's still opportunity to rank.
I could care less if you're a lead generator, if you're yellow pages, if you're Joe Schmo
down the corner, I don't care.
For me personally, I've gotten multiple deals where I've noticed one to two lead generators
sites.
Not only do I see their sites, but they're ranking on page one.
I still go into that niche.
I still build the site.
I still land a client that I've had for over two years.
I can think of two examples of done that.
So now, you know, if, if, if, if the lead generators are the only ones running ads,
that tells me that clearly there's a market because somebody's buying those beats.
Yeah.
It looks like it's going to be like a head on competition.
Well, that's the thing is go back to go back to module one though.
It does.
Does it still check the box?
Are those sites really?
Do they have good?
Do they have good backlinks?
Are they ranked?
No, no, no.
So like the backlinks are not there like the other people in the maps on page one as well.
No, then go for it.
Go for it.
Who gives a shit what they are.
I don't care.
I do not care who you are.
If, if that due diligence part checks out, I'm in.